was machen wir
ceausescus und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge teams zweifel games
die serie bettertogether wird
fortgeführt heute mit dem
unwahrscheinlich gut aussehen
denn von 100 prozentig logischen gast
bürgerkriegs immer irgendwie cash money
money
danke danke
den linken und rechten schönheit hatte
nichts computer in dieser frühen phase
leute mit seinem bruder
ich habe mir gerade eben einfach
bratkartoffeln gemacht und ich habe kurz
mit dem gedanken gespielt ob ich wieder
einen essay kocht video machen soll
aber da hab ich mir auch gedacht
minecraft minecraft dann doch nicht dann
muss auch com
außerdem erwischt ja aber der 1
was mit alexa der sub gehören
hier finde ich nicht von dem typ ich
komm prozent top teams verboten
digital ii schaut schon mal recht aufs
bild so was du da ließ ich weiß ja nicht
fehlt bei mir videos erlaubt da ist der
coole helm da bin ich mal machen
16 ja aber ist machen wir das nur
eisbergs machen die houdini und da
klingt das manchmal auch als hätten die
irgendwie so tourette syndrom oder sowas
ja diesen bisschen daneben diese leute
was ihr euch auf jeden fall auch sagen
wollte ich hab mir eine kleinigkeit
zusammenstellen lassen für euch zum 10k
special deswegen hat er auch noch so
lang gedauert okay wie ein kompass der
ist relativ nutzlos und welche den
nächsten ließen ihr könnt ihr mal in den
kommentaren schon mal raten was das sein
könnte was ich da für euch habe machen
lassen
und ich denke mal das wird euch gut
gefallen ist eine sache die auch die
auch nützlich ist die verwenden könnt
sag ich jetzt mal okay und damit habe
ich wahrscheinlich schon viel zu viele
anspielungen gemacht an jeder weißen
toast eines käfers ein sp marken tust ja
ja doch klar wer also er wäre ein wenig
klein und praktisch jeder kann ihn
benutzen werden wenn man ihm wäre
möglich was wäre butt moment was wäre
das nicht möglich muss die doch sehr
bitten da und kommt nur einer
ich würde sagen wir könnten eigentlich
hier auf die finger gehen so wenn die
dann kommen die glaub ich nicht direkt
an unseren jahr ist übrigens noch was zu
essen
der bestandsaufbau und ich wir müssen
rausgehen das rausgehen sind da steht
einer vor der tür steht die machen vier
sterne oder zwar durch die kollektoren
der 1000 drachen taktik die machen die
carsten taktik gefragt was macht mein
gott was war das denn alter wir haben
wir das hier geschafft ich habe schon
voll damit damit abgeschlossen hat
geklappt als er da hast du mir auf jeden
fall das leben gerettet ich komplett
ohne schwert denn einfach so richtig
dauern die mäßig gegen die leiter gelang
geil alter glück gehabt glück gehabt
dass zwei ausnahmen auf so engem raum
das war richtig
ja ich hatte ja nur haut also ich hab da
so du hast du dir nicht so die
möglichkeiten der leute auseinander zu
nehmen
ich habe nämlich meinen doch sehr
begrenzten mitteln die jetzt eigentlich
nur aus einer faust bestanden habe ich
eine schade ist es dass der kompass
nicht funktioniert für mich da hätte man
jetzt weil also früher als hier noch das
team plugin aktiver okay würde die faxen
zu machen
ansonsten war da noch mit dem team mit
dem kompass noch andere leute finden
mittlerweile zeit bis ihm auf den
eigenen team partner wenn er in der nähe
ist was ich jetzt nicht so nicht allzu
logisch ist sondern eher so ein bisschen
unlogischen unlogisch ja unlogisch also
mumm gespielt von tecan ja eigentlich
auch immer wenn ich unglaublich sage
dann ist ja quasi auch um gespielt aber
ja ich hab mir grad vorgestellt wie das
aussehen würde also unlogisch werden
wohl so sein partner channel von die
rundum gespielt was dürfen wir erwarten
in nächster zeit also ist auf alle fälle
in die tiefe schreiben alles klar
das war schön reißerisch muss mir
überlegen ob ich wirklich so weiß sein
will youtube haben ja jetzt wirklich
riskieren
hast du dich drauf kein bringst du
bringst ist übrigens der nicht wissen
wirklich es riskieren klicks zu
generieren
da habe ich das gefühl habe ich noch
voll die geile story die kann ich hier
mal raus hauen wir heraus als an einem
etwas älteren herrn schön aber im kopf
geblieben
dann habe sich zum treffen sich zum
alkohol konsumieren
mit ihrem motorrad und einer mit dem
oppelt und dann sagt der eine
machst du hast du ihn nicht drauf dann
schaut er das ding vor hoch knallt mit
dem vorderreifen auf das ding platz
einfach extrem land fließen diesem monat
das ganze noch mit diesem alter ich kann
diese diese story oder diesen pott kenne
ich aus new kids wurde china liefermann
ups aus diesem rasen der moped kommt nur
das unter der eine von judiths so
wird die künftigen trilogie und china so
klar wie dem unterschied das ist
wirklich passé alter dass gegner der ist
gerät durch der ist kritisch der macht
den hasen danach den hasen limmat der
macht den logischen rasen alter anpassen
heute kriegt weil ich versuche ich ein
bisschen zu pusten
wir hatten das vorher gesetzt wenngleich
er mache jetzt mal den logischen hasen
okay erklärt auf jeden fall geschickt
das feuer ja der machten sie für das ist
derzeit mit mindestens fünf blöcke
abstand macht ihn statt von ihm weg ab
hat geschrieben arm eindeutig haben arme
am körper damit ihn gerade und es
wichtig wird er sofort für beide
optieren sollen in dem kontext weil das
land gehen und da die einzustellen
in dem fall waren eindeutig vermehrte
einsatz von davon beinen zu bemerken in
der szene wird gerade weggelaufen sind
deswegen würde ich sagen arm
guter versuch aber trifft jetzt hier
nicht auf den punkt man hört ihm
gleichende neuen geben ja also ja gut so
kulant sein darum ist übrigens noch ein
ganz schwerer gegeben übrigens auch
heiltränke solltest du dich jemals
innerlich verletzt fühlen dann schmeiß
ich dir in deinen körper rein da drüben
ist
ich bin ich bei dir ich bin ich bei dir
ne ich habe den job verloren
das noch einer
kritischer ist der typ c die alter geht
was ach quatsch schreibst du willst 87
ich warte so sehr ich sehe mich so sehr
nach meinem neuen pc also wenn er
bestellte ich hab jetzt
wahrscheinlichkeit gesehen als solche
situation ist das bild immer ein
bisschen minimal rock creek und wenn ich
bin ein pc ab dann habe ich 123456
frames also 1009 12.300 89 dollar
nein bin ich dumm 123456 12 1356 junge
wusste alter du hast mich so geil in den
gebieten mit dem fall
dann hab ich dem eine 23 45 grad
nein nein nein nein das ist quatsch oder
so von pixel sowie letzten video von max
gesehen mit ja irgendwie halt dich wie
die war so lustig vom von max und und
justin wie die einfach so rappen und das
tier dann irgendwas immer schneller so
hallo hallo du kleiner zitzen becker für
beraten mitarbeiter vom schlecker und
ich so was bin ich für ein spaß ich sah
ich bin doch ich muss dabei selbst
facebook es dumm walter alt spielen
dieser runde der letzten acht ist also
falls ihr niemand sehen wollte 20.000
besser ist als ich in pvp da ich den
guten willen fall schlechten tag
erwischte ich hoffe es hat mir das
löscht dieses video ein forscher
erinnerung
das auto macht jetzt den men in black
hatte eigentlich vor die lesern ute
zimmer dem gedächtnis löscher hat
einfach alle hier in den die fans kam
und jetzt erklärt sich alles vergessen
ok jetzt können wir das ja falsch machen
okay ich war in der runde voll gut ich
hab alle zerstört er war halt nicht so
eine erwartete nächsten wir werden auch
eine folge für ihn auf das heißt wenn
ihr uns mal auf seinem channel sehen
wollt oder noch mehr für uns beiden
danach seien vorbei also mein ratschlag
ich hab jetzt doch durchaus maibock auf
der ein oder anderen fight gegen den
kämpfen wir mit bürsten schwertner
machen
die rea die axt oder er mit der axt hast
du die racks alles klar
weil ich übrigens ist im schnitt
ok 21 ich habe vier heißt je mehr bitte
12 ich hätte gegeben werden ist linie
jedoch insgesamt zu tun
ok ok ich hab keinen guten tag ok
erreichte geschwindigkeit und wähnte
sich der logo mit dem alter
das war knapp ja das ist wahr das war
das feuer das war das feuer wasser was
mit der stadt okay wir übrigens erst mal
du denkst jetzt mal deinen puls wieder
auf von 200 wie darf ein architekt der
im esch und abschluss fazit resümee was
wir jetzt noch dafür zusammenfassung ist
lass den daumen nach oben da natürlich
gefallen hat mir mehr von sehen wollt
gerne auch einen kommentar zu schreiben
mit allem was ich gerade so beschäftigt
sondern sie uns beim nächsten video
wieder wenn ihr logo abgecheckt es in
der beschreibung
bis dann macht